this is the last lesson in the grammar
of words where we're going to explore
some of the properties that don't become
apparent until we put multiple words
together but that are still often
reflected in the form of words remember
that this entire time we've been
concerned with form morphology so let's
consider four properties
possession modification agreement and
government let's stick with those four
for now starting with possession it has
a fairly descriptive name you can
probably guess that it tends to deal
with one noun possessing another now and
that's the gist of it in English we show
possession by adding an apostrophe s
suffix or clinic to the noun that is the
possessor and placing that noun before
the noun that is the possessed now an
example would make this clearer John's
car or the dogs bone both of these
examples used the Ala morph of the
apostrophe s morpheme to show possession
other languages show possession in other
ways for instance the Romance languages
used porifera --ss so does modern German
in languages that have one a genitive
case is perfectly fine for showing
possession so for instance in Latin
Ganesa Pele would be the girl's dog and
in that instance we do the reverse of
English in the romance languages a
periphrastic construction developed that
replaced the old Latin construction so
you say the equivalent of the dog of the
girl in basically every Romance language
let's move on to agreement agreement
involves one word matching the same
property of another word that's an
awkward way to say it but let me give
you some examples in Spanish a masculine
noun will be described by an adjective
that takes a masculine ending a feminine
that takes a feminine ending we sum that
up by saying that the noun and the
adjective agree the adjective agrees
with the now that's a case of agreement
the same thing happens in English
between subject nouns and verbs the word
talks agrees with he so we would expect
to say he talks but not I talks or you
talks so talks agrees with the
third-person singular subject that's
another case of agreement
the verb has to take a third person
singular affix to show that it agrees
with the third person singular subject
let's distinguish agreement from
government the traditional account of
government has this look at the word
that is governing in other words we look
for a word that forces another word to
comply with a certain property that's
another awkward definition but let's
move on to some examples in English we
have prepositions if they take a pronoun
in other words if they govern a pronoun
like me we expect that the preposition
is followed by an object pronoun rather
than a subject pronoun in other words
the word accompanying the preposition
must be in the object of case so I would
say for me but not for he I instead say
for him I don't use the subject case
pronoun after the preposition for or any
preposition for that matter I use the
object case so we say that prepositions
in English govern the accusative case of
pronouns or the object case of pronouns
it's very important to notice that
government applies to verbs as well if I
say I saw him the verb see here in the
past tense saw prompts us to use an
object case pronoun him rather than
another subject case pronoun that's
another example of government contrast
this with agreement agreement matches a
property equally while government pushes
a word to have a property that the other
word doesn't have now let's talk about
modification when an optional word is
added that changes the meaning of
another word it modifies that other word
adjectives and adverbs are the main
modifiers in English we have an example
like the grey cat ate dinner in which
gray is an adjective that modifies cat
you can see that if we remove grey the
cat still makes sense
adverbs work similarly for instance if I
say the rabbit runs swiftly swiftly
modifies how the rabbit runs we could
just say that the rabbit runs the extra
material isn't necessary but it does add
something it modifies the action notice
that these properties start to push us
away from looking at the form of words
we're already talking about the
arrangement the order of words and
sentences and with that you're ready to
move on to the grammar of sentences
I'm glad you stuck with me throughout
this series and thank you for learning
with me
you